tél dans ce laboratoire de l'école de
technologie supérieure ibrahim hussein
et son équipe simule micro réseaux
énergétiques ses disjoncteurs représente
le village et ses maisons isolées coupée
du réseau électrique autonome le village
tire son énergie d'une éolienne et de
panneaux solaires une autonomie qui
passe aussi par un parc de batterie mais
batterie chargée pour les jours sans
soleil ni vent et finalement d'une
génératrices au diesel
lorsque plus rien ne fonctionne pour
optimiser le tout on ajoute une touche
d'intelligence artificielle
actuellement il faut plus trop sur
l'intelligence artificielle comme
utilisé par google facebook et se tord à
amazon non on est capable d'utiliser
dans pas mal de domaines tels que le
domaine est rejetée bien qu'elle soit
inépuisable les énergies renouvelables
ont un gros défaut elle fluctue selon la
force des vents et les périodes
d'ensoleillement cette énergie elle
n'est pas stable et vu qu'elle n'est pas
stable dans quelque peu perturbé le
réseau
l'intelligence artificielle peut
contenir dans l'augmentation de ce soit
appelle la stabilité du réseau eau dont
la robustesse de réseau parce qu il peut
analyser en compte unités en temps réel
et dans quelques fractions de seconde la
qualité de l'électricité fournie
ici le village et les sources d'énergie
sont interconnectés et convergent vers
l'intelligence artificielle tout est
conçu de manière à prioriser
l'utilisation des énergies renouvelables
et à minimiser le recours aux énergies
fossiles comme le diesel des
génératrices là on peut observer
l'intérêt de l'intelligence artificielle
dans un micro réseaux hybrides
multisource c'est par exemple au niveau
de la gestion du flux d'énergie non
comment on peut répartir la l'énergie et
la puissance entre les différentes
sources les différentes charges
il est 14 heures le soleil est chaud le
vent souffle
l'intelligence artificielle stocke
l'énergie produite par l'éolienne
elle juge que les panneaux solaires
suffisent à alimenter le village en
énergie 17 heures la demande en énergie
explose
mais les nuages sont apparus aucun
problème
l'intelligence artificielle puise dans
le parc de batteries pour développer de
telles stratégies de consommation
l'intelligence artificielle doit
disposer d'une puissance de calcul
imposante à titre exemple dans une
éolienne on peut aller chercher 200
informations par seconde
donc si on veut traiter ceux d'essence
d'information par seconde on ne peut pas
notre cerveau va voir va éclater nom
qu'on a besoin d intelligence des ânes
bolide intelligent qui traitent ces
informations pour optimiser le réseau
les algorithmes à la base de
l'intelligence artificielle doit être
nourrie d'une grande quantité de données
diverses ceux des données aussi
opérationnels dans des informations
opérationnelles comme un des paramètres
comme la tension la fréquence la
pression aussi de d'où il l'air la
température les débits les flux et au
rock
l'intelligence artificielle doit aussi
anticiper les habitudes des résidants la
préparation des repas le lavage
le tout en fonction des aléas de la
météo et la performance des sources
d'énergie verte
l'intelligence artificielle va faire des
liens que l'humain ou quand un
contrôleur qui est programmée de façon
traditionnelle
on ne pourra pas faire donc d efficience
encore plus grandes sont allés chercher
grâce à des institutions sorties sites
reliés au réseau d'hydro-québec
l'intelligence artificielle pourrait
donc générer des économies en période de
pointe il fort à parier que
l'intelligence artificielle va jouer un
rôle important ce pas prépondérant à
moyen long terme dans les ressens tu
raison un réseau qui devra supporter des
besoins énergétiques de plus en plus
grands on pense notamment à l'arrivée
masse et des voitures électriques sur un
marché
[Musique]